hey Luke here at the outdoor boys
YouTube channel and welcome to part 2 of
our Alaska trip
[Music]
[Music]
sadly go get a fish Nathan well my
brother and nephews showed up and we're
gonna try to see if we can't catch a
salmon or two before we take off and do
a little hunting so you're doing a great
job keeping them away from the water
their ransom I really appreciate them
gonna catch him you see yeah see this is
what happens after they spawn oh yeah or
she's about to spawn yeah that's it Oh
Pacific salmon they they swim upstream
spawn once and then they die you see
she's got these little yellow spots in
her skin she's starting to decay already
and you'll see this there'll be
thousands of dead along the river by the
end of the day run
well we were hoping to pull out one more
salmon before we headed off on our
hunting trip but yeah you know that's
how it is that's why they call it
fishing right so but we got to pack up
and do some driving cuz we got to get to
the Natali's highway hey are you
stepping on my rod
before we take off and go hunting need
to load up on some protein we are going
to we're gonna make some serious steaks
here oh yeah that's what we're talking
about right there
oh you guys want some steak yeah Tommy
having a good time like your dinner
good we got enough here you think this
is wrong
I brought a suitcase undi got my
mani-pedi kit in there you know my
facials filming you work yeah
[Music]
okay this trip hunting trip just got
started where is he yes did one in the
chamber it's on safety okay so a spruce
grouse ran across the road and flew up
into one of the trees well you got away
this time
but that's a really good sign when we've
made it only a couple hundred yards and
we already saw one this trip is off to a
good start we're gonna drive for about
two hours up to Cantwell May we're in a
camp and hopefully tomorrow we're gonna
shoot ourselves I caribou or something
else we'll really see pretty much
anything
[Music]
my fear is that potassium permanganate
and with soap wizard so 101 ratio that's
just magnesium I use the water but it's
a oxidant and you stick a little
glycerin on top of it that was okay I
got a little bit of a confession to make
last night I ended up eating like two
whole steaks huge ones yep and it was
awesome until I woke up in the middle of
the night with this horrible like
heartburn the flavor of steaks and I got
out of the tent and just threw up
everywhere take it a little easy this
morning I may not eat steak again for a
little while we're seeing in the world
is barfing your brains out and then
having Montreal steak seasoning go up in
your nose it'll turn you off alright
let's keep going
all right you guys ready to go get some
caribou good do it alright so I'm here
with my brother and we are on the Denali
Highway and our goal today is to shoot
something we are hoping for a caribou
but we will take a spruce grouse some
ptarmigan Fair wolf I mean this this is
a big list it's a big tent everyone's
welcome and the Denali Highway is an
interesting place this is the Denali
Highway
it's a two-lane dirt road that's about
120 miles long 140 miles long connects
two of our highways and they're not
really anything on it there's no cities
or anything in between there there might
be a gas station somewhere on this
Highway but uh as you can see we use the
term highway very loosely here in Alaska
so but anyway we're gonna spend most of
day a driving through stopping and
Glasson for a caribou and maybe captain
some grayling and we're gonna have a fun
time all right we're gonna get on top of
this little knob here start glassing see
if we can see anything
who's there might be pull a bear tracks
[Music]
well we found an airstrip that's Alaska
for you it's random air strips out in
the middle of nowhere
blueberries everywhere here just pick it
up with your fingers no watermelon berry
bush so many berries crowberries down
here see those are watermelon berries
yeah put your mouth in the seat yeah oh
look there's a dead caribou alright just
need to find the rest of it
[Music]
ah I haven't fly fish for grayling and
forever one of my favorite fish to catch
on a fly we're gonna see if there's any
in here but this is a good looking spa
Hey look at this isn't this a beautiful
fish off they're so gorgeous and they
are just amazing fun on a dry flock
that's the first started grilling I
thought in many years and it was just as
awesome as I remember I would get some
more of those I can see the grayling
down in here the water is so crystal
clear I bet if I stick my GoPro down on
the water you guys will be able to see
them too
[Music]
like gorgeous switched over from an elk
hair caddis to a mosquito pattern
[Music]
look at the colors on these fish are
they not just incredibly gorgeous
this has just been amazing but we've got
to go get set up you've got 40 miles yet
to travel so better get back on the road
this is a lovely diversion Tommy you
feeling warmer can you say salam alayka
very nice
all right listen let's catch him fish
okay so this is like muskeg and this is
what Tundra looks like and you can see
right there that that cut area right in
there that's where permafrost has been
exposed and is melting
that's a good-looking Creek we are going
to go and do a little gravy fishing well
this looks pretty awesome let's see if
we can't get a grayling or two
dan
dan dan dan
it's officially a hunting trip and a
successful hunting trip
nice oh yeah yeah I flush up to others
yeah look at that Tommy pretty cool want
to see a little prize surprise okay
there you go I saved a head for you you
want to hold it and check this out come
see see look how he's starting to turn
white see they turn white in the
wintertime and in the summertime they're
brown and right now it's the fall so
he's half and half he's half white and
half brown asked a state bird right
there mom's gonna be so proud
don't don't like it don't like the head
we went hunting and we killed something
and shut to go in a whole bunch
[Music]
what's that you go one step tell me
about the claw you had a collection of
claws and bird heads there you go not a
ton of meat but there's a ptarmigan you
can Oh seat the gizzards in the hearts
and some of the other organs but I I'm
not really gonna do that today
[Music]
we're gonna try roasting a tart we get
like we do marshmallows and we're gonna
season the ptarmigan with some of this
Montreal steak seasoning which after
last night I don't know if I'm ready for
but all we have I'm not much of a chef
when it comes to wild meat but one thing
about is they're very lean
ptarmigan has almost no fat in it so if
you slow roast it like a chicken I think
it's gonna end up pretty tough so
instead I'm gonna try to sear it a
little bit I could be doing it
completely wrong though looks pretty
good still still pretty soft not too bad
still a little pink on the inside
there's really quick to cook I mean I
think it was only in the fire like two
three minutes max yeah yeah I think
that's the key just go real quick yeah
come on I'll show you the pump see that
big handle grab that handle let's start
pumping that up and down
tell me are you upset by through the
ptarmigan hit away were you gonna
collect it oh I'm sorry buddy we had to
throw it away yeah mom doesn't want us
bringing that home feel a little better
yeah good good marshmallow Tom
[Music]
well it's 6:30 in the morning and I'm
the only one up so I'm gonna go do a
little fishing here I'll let everybody
wake up on their own time this looks
promising
very good you know they're just an
amazingly beautiful fish and they always
love to take dry flies
let's get you back in the water we used
to come here all the time as kids about
once a year our family would take the
motorhome up here we'd camp and pick
blueberries and catch grayling when I
think about this place I think about
eating homemade pancakes that my mom
would make with blueberries we picked
the day before
oh you got such stinking small mouths
and he's got all three Barb's in him
jeez okay we get my four sets out oh
look at that got a mouth that takes me
back man that's old school for me this
is how I grew up fishing right here I
got to tell you I'm really excited about
breakfast I've got a big thing of fresh
berries and some oatmeal I'm really
looking forward to you it's gonna be
good
oh yeah I got a couple o couple
Grayling's well Tommy have you had a
good trip you'd like camping
[Music]
all right Tommy ready for some blueberry
oatmeal to go Tommy Lou is that good
yeah that's good stuff look at this rose
hips watermelon berries crow berries
blueberries this is breakfast a champion
that is so good
well we've had a good time here on the
Denali highway but it's time to break
camp and get headed home we have about a
five and a half six hour drive back to
Anchorage and I'm looking forward to
seeing my wife and little Nathan so
we're gonna gonna get going
there's lots of places in the US we can
go and see nature the difference with
Alaska is the sheer volume of it
this is pretty much what we've been
doing for the last two days and nothing
it's just gorgeous
yeah still stop it and check it for
caribou
[Music]
hey there's the Alaska Pipeline up on
the horizon
the frenzy
go follow him back in it if there's a
clearing back in there you get a shot
is crazy
we saw three caribou running across the
road right in front of us so we get out
of the car go chasing after him
see if we can find an open spot we ran
across it's probably seven caribou kills
just in this short period of time there
are tons and tons of caribou droppings
caribou trails over here but it's so
thick yeah I just don't we get an open
shot but man there's tons of them in
here and we're supposed to be home in a
little bit so we're gonna pile back in
the car and keep driving down the road
was that fun yeah I went how about you
guys
I got my daddy's own dirty Tommy I think
you're one of the few people in the
world that has gone caribou hunting in
their pajamas
all right let's get some food thank you
so let me show you what $14 can buy you
with rural Alaska a Hawaiian burger
dummy you like your hot dog all right we
stopped in downtown Eureka to get some
gas
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
well hopefully you liked this video and
if you'd like to see more videos like it
check out part 3 of our Alaskan
adventure and don't forget to click
subscribe to get more videos from the
outdoor boys YouTube channel we put out
new videos every week also if you'd like
to learn more about how to catch clean
and cook wild Alaskan salmon don't
forget to check out this video from the
catfish and carp YouTube channel I'll
put a link in the description thanks for
watching